we've reached it we've reached that
moment i've seen
many shows do before and that's the
moment where they're like hey
we have only six episodes to tell our
story what are we gonna do
have an entire episode that just feels
like filler
why i mean it did have that moment where
loki takes a drink and says another and
smashes the cup on the ground i was like
hey that's a great callback
drink i like them another that's how
they get down in asgard i like that rest
of the episode
felt a lot like filler because you have
loki and variant look you have the
lokian loki buddy cop episode
and they spend about 40 minutes looking
for a cell phone charger so at the end
of the last episode loki meets variant
loki he meets lady loki they go through
the quantum leap door long story short
in this episode they end up on this
planet where this planet's colliding
with this moon which is weirdly phrased
i feel like the planet would have a
stronger gravitational pull
than the moon so technically speaking
the moon's crashing into the planet but
the way they phrase is the planets
crashing into the moon fair but the
quantum leap door device is out of juice
so they just they walk around
looking for a way to charge it but with
loki hanging out with lady loki it's
like all right ask the questions loki
should have been like right out the gate
before we started paling around with her
should have been like okay
who are you what's your story where are
you coming from what's your end game
which he asks
some of those questions but you get
really vague
answers that just frustrated me let me
take the variant thing you know there's
gonna be overlap with their lives he was
like i just found out i was adopted not
too long ago she was like oh i always
knew i was adopted and he was like
really like in terms of her story this
is what you end up knowing by the end of
this episode
she was adopted and she knew that
and that's it i mean that is so vague
you're dealing with the variant you want
to know what the variant elements are
it's like oh
are you were you on asgard variant
odin and variant rene russo are they
your variant parents are you a frost
giant do you know you're a frost giant
is your biological dad a frost giant
king like if there's a variant
me out there it's like where'd you grow
up new york which is not where i grew up
who are your parents
other people who are not your parents
i'm like okay so
you're not a variant me you're just
another person i feel like she's just
another person and if you're not going
to give me the details of her variant
loki life
at least give me the details of what's
her motivation what's she going for
what does she have against the tva how
does she see them which i feel like is
probably tied with who she is and where
she comes from at this point i'm
starting to think she was
probably a brainwashed tva agent who's
not actually a loki varying she makes
this vague reference and passing about
loki working for the fascist
organization of the tva which is great i
started thinking about that
after the last episode that they were
actually the bad guys but
i'd like to know a little more about why
she feels that way and this matters
on two fronts one from the audience's
perspective you want to know a little
more about lady loki because the entire
episode has you hanging out with her and
if you don't give the audience more
about her then they're hanging out with
the characters they don't care about
which is how i felt and with loki's
perspective i feel like he would pry a
little more than he did
i don't think he would roll with the
vague answers he got he's all like so
what are you after
i don't know like stop
well that's good enough for me loki's
just kind of going into this whole thing
blind like yeah i'll hang out with her
and not know jack [ __ ] about her
that's fine like if it wouldn't be
enough for me i really feel like it
wouldn't be enough for the master
manipulator that
is the god of mischief there's this
connection between loki and lady loki
like they trust each other she even says
like do we trust each other and loki's
like we do loki
god of mischief zero trust issues
you don't even need trust issues just be
cautious there's no reason for you to
trust her
i wouldn't trust her granted i wouldn't
trust loki either that's just called
being smart and i feel like the show
with lady loki is falling into this trap
that falcon and the winter soldier fell
into with
what's her name from that organization
that i can't remember where it's like oh
here's the villain but we're gonna make
her very sympathetic
but with in falcon and the winter
soldier was like no you bombed buildings
and killed people so
no i think you're just a dick in loki
there's a possibility that the tva is a
bigger villain than lady loki and the
fact that we find out
other important information in this
episode where she was like tva
agents they were just people you know
like some of them are i'm sure they're
from
a lot of other worlds like asgard and
other worlds where people look like
humans from earth but we find out they
don't know that these tva agents don't
know where they come from they think
they were created by these
time lords and they weren't it's all a
lie which again that's cool that's
actually compelling lady loki is going
to burn a system to the ground that's
great and the way she says it implies
that she empathizes with that she's like
they don't know that it's like oh yeah
they're victims you get it as i burn
them alive like i'm a monster in a
horror movie
so i mean does she really get it this
there's conflict among the writing and
they've done this before and i
i see this is a repeating pattern i feel
like the time in an mcu series
they had a sympathetic villain was when
they had one by accident when it was
wanda because i don't think they
actually
knew that wanda was the villain when
they made the show but logistically
she was and when they try to do it on
purpose you see conflicting concepts in
the writing you even see that with loki
a bit
you know this whole world's gonna die
like everyone on this planet
is going to die and they have to get to
the ship that's going to get off the
planet and he says something like all
these people are gonna die
which i do think loki would think about
about the time of avengers end game
maybe
but this loki just got done sacking new
york what does he give a [ __ ]
look to your elder people
let him be an example i get that he saw
a film reel of his entire life and
destiny and death and
that probably changes a bit of his
perspective but that's not the same as
years of experience that will lead you
to that sense of
moral enlightenment couple thoughts i do
have is lady loki says
with the strong minds you know the
strong-minded people you have to play
the long game and create a whole fantasy
reality based off of their mind which
makes me think at the end of this show
maybe the second to last episode uh
we're gonna find out that loki was
inside his head this episode and the
next two were just gonna be a fantasy
lie
in which she's trying to hack his brain
and this episode also showed me how much
owen wilson
adds to the intrigue of the show because
he is he's apparently a big part of it
he's a big part of the draw
he and loki are what i like about the
show not loki
and other loki i just don't care
regardless loki
lady loki and or both i feel like
they're going to succeed at the end of
this
and trashing this universal timeline
that's supposed to be the one timeline
because it sounds like if they do
succeed there's going to be some sort of
multiverse of madness which is
apparently actually going to happen so
regardless one thing remains we are all
in a reality where apparently
that adam warlock post credit scene
doesn't mean jack [ __ ]
is it ever gonna matter did that happen
and in the end this was a really
frustrating episode from the fact that
we only have six episodes of the show
and this was a filler episode when we
don't have time for filler episodes the
fact that loki is not really acting like
loki as he should be acting in this
phase of his life fact that the episode
had us palling around with lady loki and
gave us
no reason to want to do that was
optimistic about the show this show had
an
early hook that really grabbed me this
episode makes me cautious going forward
alright so episode 3 of loki what did
you think about it did it feel like
filler did you get the answers you
wanted do you think there's a bigger
thing happening do you think she's
actually a variant loki because i don't
not at this point whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you